groups of family and friends gathered in
New York's Central Park in fine weather
on Sunday police were on hand to remind
them to keep the recommended distance
most appeared to comply and many New
Yorkers wore masks
this Memorial Day weekend on the pages
of one of the city's newspapers a
different kind of memorial names and
brief descriptions of some of the nearly
100,000 US residents who have died from
kovat 19 the headline read an
incalculable loss elsewhere people
partied on beaches along the East Coast
and congregated outside a bar in
Pennsylvania dancing and listening to
live bands they appeared to ignore
warnings from public health experts that
crowds create the danger of a new spike
in kovat 19 cases when you go out for
this weekend a Memorial Day and you want
to do a some kind of social gathering
it's very important to maintain that six
feet distance and very important to have
your mask with you in case that six feet
different distance cannot be maintained
President Donald Trump who last week
made a show of demanding that houses of
worship be opened across the country
this weekend skipped Church in favor of
golf for the second day in a row he was
not seen wearing a mask some churches
did open in Massachusetts a Roman
Catholic priest greeted parishioners
outside Saint John the Evangelist Church
but other pastors perhaps mindful of the
verse in the Bible that says to
everything there is a season decided the
time was not ripe we're not ready and we
are not going to open our doors until we
believe that everybody is going to be
able to stay safe a country eager to
return to normal but divided over what
normal has become rob reynolds al
jazeera